for the past five days Ukrainian cities
have faced one of the heaviest aerial
bombardments of the war Russia claims it
has been using Precision weapons but
Charlie dagada and his team on the
ground in one hard hit City with
evidence that civilians also appear to
be in Vladimir Putin's crosshairs
every teams clearing the debris of a
collapsed building in zapparesia pause
to get a closer look as delicately as
they could manage they carry the body
out
this is the moment in the aftermath of
every attack like these when the heavy
equipment stops the rescue teams go
quiet as they recover another victim
from beneath the rubble
children's clothes hang from the trees
blown out by the force of the blast
there are no military targets here
and Alina gracienko were asleep at
around 2 A.M when two missiles tore
through this neighborhood
said they helped evacuate elderly women
from the higher floors
outside the cars had all burst into
flames they were both injured by flying
glass
but Alina now Bears scars that run much
deeper how are you doing now
I'm afraid of the huge noises and
explosions she said now I start to panic
from every little air raid alert you
were here they showed us their apartment
the walls and ceilings shredded by
shrapnel that soared across the room
outside they pick up the pieces
survivors Salvage whatever they can and
brace for the night to come for CBS
mornings Charlie dagina zapparesia
Ukraine